>> Greg: LET'S TAKE A TEST.
IN TERMS OF SUCCESS, WOULD YOU
RATHER BE?
PERSPECTIVE.
GIVEN THAT MOST POLLS SHOW
WIDESPREAD APPROVAL, UPWARDS OF
JUAN.
AS TRUMP MENTIONED, THEY
FROWNED.
ONE CLOWN BOLTED WHEN A
PATRIOTIC CHANCE BROKE OUT.
AND THEY SPEAK OF DIVISION.
THEY SAT WHEN THEY SHOULD'VE
STOOD.
EVEN FOR THE FLAG.
DO YOU THINK AMERICANS DIDN'T
NOTICE THAT?
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CONFUSED.
TRUMP IS HITTING THE HIGH NOTES
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
ALWAYS SCOWLING AT GOOD NEWS.
SCHUMER LOOKED LIKE HE DIDN'T
KNOW WHETHER TO WIND HIS WATCH
HER CRY.
PELOSI LOOKS LIKE SHE DISCOVERED
HER CHAUFFEUR HAD JUST BROKEN
WIND.
SOMEONE SHOULD HAVE CHECKED ON
IF THE OLD SAYING IS TRUE, THAT
PROGRESSIVISM IS THE FEAR THAT
SOMEONE SOMEWHERE IS MAKING
AMERICA LOOK GOOD, THEN THIS WAS
A REALLY BAD NIGHT FOR
PROGRESSIVES.
>> IMMIGRATION IS IS ONE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A BIG
SUCCESS QUICKLY BUT I HAVE TO
TELL YOU I THINK HIS RHETORIC
LAST NIGHT SET THINGS BACK, DID
NOT ADVANCE THE BALL FORWARD.
>> CALLING THIS A HEALING SPEECH
IS ALMOST LIKE CALLING GOING ON
A DIET DRINKING DIET COKE AND
EATING PIZZA.
>> YOU TELL ME THAT ROOM IS
SUPPOSED TO RESPOND LIKE THIS TO
THE GREAT DICTATOR?
>> Greg: THAT WAS LIKE HER
WHEN HE WAS RUNNING.
TRUMP SET A TRAP FOR THE DEMS
EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY.
IN POLITICS, SOMEONE HAS TO BE
JESSE, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
DO YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE
PEOPLE WHO SHOUTED AT OBAMA
DURING ONE SPECIFIC EVENT I
CAN'T REMEMBER.
>> Jesse: YOU LIVE?
JOE WILSON.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS LOOK LIKE
THE MEDIA, OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF HE DESERVES MORE CREDIT FOR
THE SUCCESS, AND THEN THE MEDIA
IS SAYING IT IS GLOOMY, DARK,
POISONOUS.
THERE'S A HUGE DISCONNECT.
YOU HAD TO BIG-TIME POLLSTERS
BOTH SAY HOME RUN.
IF HE CONTINUES TO PERFORM LIKE
THIS, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY MAY
SAVE THE HOUSE AND SENATE AND
HE'S GOING TO EVEN WIN
REELECTION.
NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT CLAP AT
SOME OF THOSE MOMENTS YOU
BROUGHT UP ABOUT RISING WAGES
AND MORE JOBS, THEY DIDN'T CLAP
WHEN THERE WAS TALK ABOUT A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP, LOWERING
DRUG PRICES, THEY DIDN'T CLAP
ABOUT DESTROYING ISIS.
THEY DIDN'T CLAP ABOUT THE
RECOVERY OF STEVE SCALISE, ONE
OF THEIR OWN COLLEAGUES.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> Kimberly: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY DID.
IT >> Jesse: NOT WHAT I SOW.
CHECK THAT DAY.
YOU CAN STILL APPLAUD THE
SUCCESS OF AMERICA BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
TRUMP SAYS.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY AGREE MORE
ABOUT THEIR PARTY THAN THEY DO
ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
IMAGINE IF THE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T
CLAP WHEN WE WON GOLD MEDAL IN
THE OLYMPICS BECAUSE TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S KIND OF THE DISCONNECT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE SOMETHING
VERY SKILLFUL HERE.
HE IS SO CLOSELY ASSOCIATED
HIMSELF WITH THE FLAG IN THE
COUNTRY AND THE ECONOMIC
ARE ROOTING AGAINST AMERICA.
HE HAS ALSO TRIANGULATED WHEN IT
COMES TO MANUFACTURING,
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND TRADE THAT
POSITION WHERE THEY ARE BOXED
IN.
ARE THEY GOING TO CHOOSE WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THEIR OWN BASE ARE THEY
GOING TO FOLLOW PELOSI AND
CRYING CHUCK?
>> Greg: I DIDN'T CONSIDER
THAT.
JESSE SAYS HE'S ALIGNED HIMSELF
KIND OF AGAINST THE FLAG.
IN A WAY IT'S ALMOST PARALLEL
THAT IF YOU ARE AGAINST
PRESIDENT OBAMA, YOU ARE A
RACIST.
CASE, IDENTITY POLITICS.
IN THIS CASE, UNIFICATION AND
PATRIOTISM.
>> Dana: WHEN THEY DIDN'T COME
OUT WHEN THE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T
STAND -- I SHOULDN'T SAY DIDN'T.
I HAD A DEMOCRAT TODAY WHO DID
STAMPER RISING WAGES.
AND THEY KNOW THAT IN THEIR
DISTRICTS ALL THE CITIZENS ARE
SEEING GOOD HEADLINES ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
SO THERE IS A DISCONNECT.
FOR PEOPLE WHO WATCHED THE
SPEECH, MOST OF THOSE TENDED TO
BE PEOPLE WHO ELECT THE
PRESIDENT ANYWAY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STARTING TO
LOSE GROUND IN THE CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE
CONSIDERABLE GROUND IN A MONTH.
I THINK WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
COULD'VE DONE FROM A
COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT IS
STOOD UP AND CHEERED AND
APPLAUDED AND GIVEN A HIGH FIVE
TO EACH OTHER SAYING "WE DID
THIS FOR YOU."
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HELPED YOU,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, TO INHERIT THIS
GREAT ECONOMY AND WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY GOING TO GO FORWARD
TO TRY TO WIN BACK THE WORKING
CLASS.
>> Greg: AND TAKE CREDIT FOR
SOME OF THE CENTRIST AND
DEMOCRATIC IDEAS HE FLOATED.
>> Dana: LIKE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
>> Greg: THERE IS SOME LIBERAL
GOOD POINT.
THERE WAS PLENTY THERE FOR THEM
TO SAY WE WERE CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS, WE HELPED.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THAT
COUNTRY TO PROSPER AS IT RELATES
TO THE ECONOMY AND TAX REFORM.
INSTEAD THEY CHOSE TO BE
PARTISAN AND NOT TO BE HONEST IN
TERMS OF OKAY, THIS IS WHAT'S
TO CONTRIBUTE.
THIS IS WHAT IN FACT IS GOOD FOR
THE COUNTRY.
THEY DID NOT WANT TO
BEGRUDGINGLY GIVE ANY CREDIT OR
KNOWLEDGE ANY PARTICIPATION
BECAUSE TO GIVE HIM ANY CREDIT
FOR HONEST TO GOD ACHIEVEMENT
WAS TOO MUCH FOR THEM TO SWALLOW
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU ARE BATTING
CLEANUP HERE.
WHY DOES YOUR SIDE LOOK LIKE A
BUNCH OF SORE LOSERS.
YOU GET TEN SECONDS.
HERE WE ARE ON FOX.
>> Greg: WE GIVE YOU MORE TIME
THAN ANYBODY ON THE PLANETS.
C7 I AM SO CURIOUS AND
LISTENING.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE YOUNG MAN AND
THE FLANKS OF THE GRAVES.
HOW CAN YOU NOT SEE THAT HE IS
GOING AFTER PEOPLE WHO SAY "I AM
HAVING A LEGITIMATE PROTEST
ABOUT POLICE BRUTALITY BY
REFUSING TO STAND AT THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM."
THAT'S A CHOICE PEOPLE ARE
MAKING.
WHAT TRUMP HAS DONE IS HE IS NOW
DEMONIZED ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T
STAND WITH THIS LITTLE BOY WHO
IS BRINGING FLAGS TO A GRAVE.
HOW CAN YOU NOT DO IT?
I WILL TELL YOU.
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO UPSET AND YOU
WANT AMERICA TO KNOW THERE IS
POLICE BRUTALITY IN THE WORLD.
WITH REGARD TO WAGES, HOW CAN
YOU NOT SAY, OH, TRUMP SAYS
I'M JUST TELLING YOU.
SO MUCH HERE THAT TRUMP STEERS
AND DISTORTS AND TWISTS AND YOU
ARE SAYING HE IS PATRIOTIC.
EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
IN TRUMP'S CASE, HE HAS THIS
YOUNG BOY ON TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AMAZING THING HE IS DOING.
THAT IS A WELL ARTICULATED
PRINCIPLE HE IS ESPOUSING.
THE KNEELING STUFF WAS POORLY
ARTICULATED.
PEOPLE HAD TO KEEP REPEATING IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
IT BECAME A QUESTION OF
PATRIOTISM, NOT A QUESTION OF
BRUTALITY.
IF THEY HAD GONE TO THEIR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND PROTESTED THERE,
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
YOU ARE COMPARING A WELL
ARTICULATED VISION WITH ONE THAT
WAS CONVOLUTED.
>> Juan: IT WASN'T CONVOLUTED.
>> Greg: IT DIDN'T WORK.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
THINK IT WORKED OR NOT BUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE SENSITIVE TO THE
ARGUMENT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIVES MATTER OR COLIN KAEPERNICK
LIVES MATTER OR COLIN KAEPERNIC
KAEPERNICK.
>> Dana: JESSE POINTED OUT
DEMOCRATS DID NOT STAND FOR
STEVE SCALISE.
I THOUGHT THEY DID.